foreign
Annie is next in Nashville hi Annie
welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you guys doing today better
than we deserve how can we help
so my husband and I are first-time home
buyers we just started the process and
I've been talking to a local mortgage
broker and he gave us some information
on 30-year versus 15-year mortgages we
want to do the 15-year we're trying to
follow the plan we have a sizable down
payment
but he did say which I thought this was
kind of strange I just don't understand
this that if we want the 15-year we are
required to do a rate buy down to get
like a little lower interest rate
um so I just didn't know what that was I
never heard of that before he said it
would be about a point or point and a
half to get the rate buy down
uh uh uh you need to call Churchill
Mortgage
and get with a new mortgage broker okay
there are two things you can do to buy
down rates uh I
think I'm hearing
that he just wants you to pay points
that is not a true buy down that's just
Points each point is one percent of the
loan amount and will reduce your
interest rate by about an eighth between
an eighth and a quarter somewhere in
there but usually around an eighth of a
percent which means it takes you eight
years to recoup that no thank you I'll
pass
so paying points is not a good thing and
I'm pretty sure by the way that
increases what goes in his pocket at the
closing that's why I'm um rolling my
eyes a bit here I don't know if you can
hear it over the radio but I was and so
um the an actual buy down is a like a
three two one buy down and it would be a
three percent reduction the first year
or a 2-1 buy down two percent reduction
the first year one percent reduction the
second year and then it goes on up to
the regular rate and all that is is
you're just giving yourself some money
up front to subsidize yourself
now if the seller pays your two one buy
down like in the old days when things
were a little calmer than they are right
now a builder might pay for a 2-1 buy
down
okay in other words they would pay two
percent pay the you know just at .02
right what it's going to cost you to
reduce the rate by two percent and then
point one so it's going to cost them
three percent out of pocket to do a 2-1
buy down or six percent out of pocket to
do a three two one buy down if the
seller pays that that's free money you
got a deal okay but if you're if you're
gonna pay for your own buy down uh
that's uh not as bad as points but it's
there's no reason to do it
okay does that make sense you understand
the difference in what I'm saying points
are prepaid interest both of these are
prepaid interest points are a form of
prepaid interest and one point will
reduce the roughly an eighth of a
percent APR for the life of the loan a
true buy down is just it's a two one buy
down age you take your current rate
let's call it six percent it'd be four
percent the first year five percent the
second year and six percent from then on
and you pay that difference up front at
the closing
which you could have just done that for
yourself if you're just swapping pockets
so actually let me think about this
Cindy if the seller's not paying it
we're going to do neither of these
that's the moral of the story
okay is the seller paying it
he acted like I was to get the 15-year
this is something I would have to do why
do a race 15 years generally cheaper
than a 30-year
anyway and are they saying you can't
qualify
so he said he said that the 30-year
would be
8 17 5 and if I 15 year would be the
same unless I did this rate buy down
then I could get like 6.5 or something
doesn't sound right new mortgage broker
new one okay he just lost the business
yeah because 15-year quoted at what we
call a par quote 0.0 origination is
always cheaper than a 30-year
okay and for you you know he's monkeying
with you to put his line in his pocket
so that's what I think I'm not a hundred
percent sure but having done about a
bazillion of these I'm pretty sure yeah
I I go to Churchill talk to them and see
if they give you the exact same thing if
they do I'll shut up and say that I was
wrong about the guy's character but
when is it better to just make a larger
down payment as opposed to attempting a
three two one the larger down payment uh
doesn't reduce well it would reduce the
payment but it doesn't reduce it as much
mathematically
um so actually it would be no it
wouldn't it wouldn't because
I guess what I'm saying is there is
there math that you need to do to find
out what that point would be no it's
it's don't subsidize your own loan is
the moral of the story both of them are
a form of subsidizing your own interest
rate prepaying it by prepaying it in
their different forms points or buy
Downs so if the seller is paying points
or the seller is paying a buy down
that's different right and all things
being equal meaning no points no
origination which is called a par quote
your 30 should match your your 15 should
be a little bit less a it should be a
quarter of a point half a point less on
your APR generally speaking it is now
there might be a glitch in the
environment at this moment in the bond
market that's doing that I I'm not 100
sure but most of the time throughout
30 almost 40 years of being in the real
estate and around real estate business
that's what my experience has been so
but double check you need to get another
quote I I'm I just smell
um I I don't it doesn't it doesn't smell
right that's all right dude just leave
it at that